hello hey what's happening buddy it's
sammy liz
yeah super well thanks um how's uh how's
things with you man
going really well um
i'm sure we've got mutual friends and
connections i'm sure i've done some
stuff with some hall players
do you know i'm sure i'm sure you're
cutting up just a bit
ah okay can you can you hear me yeah
i was just saying i'm sure we've done
stuff with some hall players before i'm
sure i mean i'm sure we've got some
mutual friends
yeah i think uh indiana spencer said
a few other they didn't take names
yeah you know um do you know kevin
stewart
yeah yeah kevin kevin's like a really
good friend of mine me and kevin
yeah we've done business together man
he's doing really well
in fact in fact kev kev is actually on
our property investors academy
really you usually do i like to give him
a shout
out okay cool so basically yeah i mean
there's a there's a massive awakening
you know within
the um you know not just football but
also
generally within the sports profession
there's awakening
that people are realizing unless they've
got some passive income as well as their
active income
potentially in a few years time there
could be a situation whereby they
they look back and kick themselves so i
mean you know you're super young how old
are you earlier
i'm 20. you just turned 20. so
you know you're super young so firstly i
just want to say respect for even
opening up yourself to the world of
property and investments
you know i think that's i think that's
incredible and we'd be very happy to
assist you in any way that we can
obviously on this call i'm happy to give
you some tips
and and if i can if i can help you with
strategy and things that would be great
uh i believe you are you booked on
discovery day as well i believe
um i'm not sure if i'm not talking i um
i signed up to uh the author last week
of course in finance amazing amazing
have you started that yet have you
started
yeah
yeah i've been going through i've seen
this um the first one
um uh just the progressive course
um so much content on this
it's wicked it's actually really really
good that's great that's great
so amazing so i mean you've done a
little bit of training you've done the
joint venture
raising finance course um i mean what is
it specifically that you felt you really
needed help with and
i mean what can i do for on this call
was um i was selling alone i went to
charlotte at the
start of the season so i was down there
and obviously i've always been
interested in property
but i just i was it was kind of on the
back um but i
i tore my acl um so i had an operation
and i'm out for nine months so you know
no [ __ ]
bad luck which is obviously going um and
now i'm up here and back up
located in hell and so i thought why not
an opportunity to
to get on the ladder up here it's a
decent area
[Music]
so i'm thinking of buying i could do it
i could buy
i could be on my deal and like buy in
low
do it out um and then instead of like
running out completely i'm thinking of
living in one of the rooms and running
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah i think it's great i think um have
you have you got people
um that would rent rooms in a in a
housing hall
yeah yeah i reckon i could easily get
three
three um
and also what about um in terms of
longevity
what would be the plan for the house in
a few years time would you sell it would
you keep it what would you do with it
i mean i i genuinely want to build a
portfolio um
i'm not really urged to sell anytime
soon because
you know the problem so i don't mind
holding it for however long
i'm honest okay so my suggestion would
be
elliot i would say buy a house in hall
you buy it as a first-time buyer you
could probably
you could probably i'd have to speak to
my mortgage broker but you could
probably get
a residential mortgage where you're
literally gonna put down like 10 15
percent so you're just gonna put down
peanuts
exactly then get a few lodges
i don't think there's anything you
should find that some lenders even if
it's a residential mortgage
should be okay with you having like a
lodger or a few lodges
because they're just your friends
they're just crashing
and they're just chipping in they're
just chipping in
you know we're not we're not you know
it's not a commercial project
it's your home but they're just chipping
in with with helping pay off the
mortgage and stuff cool
then maybe fix it up a little bit
try and increase the value a little bit
then in
a year or two years or three years you
could sell that property you've got
you've built you've got it
that property is going to give you
landlord experience it's going to mean
it's going to open you up to more
lending elsewhere
it's going to give you credibility in
the property industry you're going to
make some money off it
and then in a few years time or whatever
i'd sell it
and you'll pay zero you'll pay zero
capital gains tax because it was your
residence
okay so you won't pay any tax you won't
pay any tax when you sell the property
because you lived in it
okay so do you feel like um selling it
a few years down the line be better than
keeping it and and
say i rented it to like just a tenant
obviously on a residential mortgage i
don't know
i don't think that's possible well you
could either in a few years time you
could either refinance it onto a
onto a buy to let mortgage or you could
sell it but the thing is if
the good thing about selling it is is is
again it's like it's like you don't pay
any tax
so yeah you're just gonna put the
profits towards some other deal but i
think you could decide
i mean you always want exit strategies
anyway but your first deal should be
a residential little three bed house
in hull turn it into a four bed fix it
up a little bit
stick a few lodges in there you're only
gonna need to put down
peanuts like maybe maybe 10 15 grand
yeah for that and you're going to be and
you're going to be living rent free
and you're going to be and you're going
to be building your experience you're
going to be building your credibility
in terms of the condition of that
property would that be like a moving
straight away probably or
would it be one that i i have to kind of
put a bit of work into build a bit
um add a bit of value to um already
just to move in probably so i mean the
advantage to
buying a property that needs work to it
um there are advantages to that you can
push the value up and stuff but to be
honest
to be honest you're probably gonna
you're gonna you're not gonna pay stamp
duty anyway because it's your first
it's your first property and it's less
than 125 grand
as a first-time buyer you pay no stamps
due today you're not going to pay
capital gains tax when you sell it
you're going to get really cheap rates
um and and i probably
would just find something that's that
doesn't need to be refurbished i mean
sure
you might put a bed in the reception
room and turn it into a bedroom but
i i'd be doing minimal work just to keep
the costs really really low
find some of this already in nice
condition i bet i could find in three
and a half minutes i bet i could jump on
right move
and i could find a nice three bed two
reception room house in hall for about
80 90 grand
yeah yeah i mean
yeah and you're gonna put down peanuts
it's gonna be a nice house
nice big rooms would be a nice home with
lodgers but that's going to open up
that's going to open up let doors for
you in from it from a lendability point
of view
um massively and it's i think i think
that would be smart
and in terms of time
don't worry about it it takes forever
for houses to complete anyway especially
if
you get a buy yeah i'd just do it now
even
even if you buy it too too quickly if it
takes two months to complete
you bear in mind you've got to find it
you've got to put an offer on it you've
got to negotiate it's going to be
accepted
you then go you then got to wait for
solicitors to do their bit then it will
probably fall through and you have to
find something else
then you gotta get your mortgage sorted
you've got to get let's say it's
record time and you get the whole thing
done in three months
yeah from finding it to getting the keys
and everything and then you've got
obviously
you know maybe doing a little bit of a
conversion even if it's on the cheap
well
it's now it's like almost december
that's march time
then great okay no problem you've got
three months where you've just got an
empty house who cares
whack it on airbnb and booking.com and
get i i i would just be moving fast now
ready for yeah
and then yeah down the line obviously i
i do want to know
well yeah i mean there's good and bad
parts of hull um
and i mean if you were looking to buy a
property
as a hmo because this won't be a hmo
this would just be your house where you
read the rooms out but if you were
looking for a hmo
i would then tell you uh i'd give you
very different advice because
because like it's really important that
you you find the exact right streets and
it's a whole beast
you know it's a whole beast but without
you can get that also another thing is
in hull like alistair for instance one
of my uh
one of my students who's now like a
really good friend of mine he he's done
hmos in hall where he's just bought them
on lease option agreement so he's put
down pretty much nothing
okay and he's because there's a lot of
negative equity in hull i would dominate
i would dominate her if i was you i'd
make call you a little [ __ ]
that's exactly what i'm thinking i would
i would do lease option agreements
i would do because the thing is if you
do if you do in the next six months if
you while this is going on
you want to be doing other stuff you
want to be doing lease option agreements
in hall
like like like like like crazy saying
to people and you don't need credit for
that you don't need a landlord
experience for that
just find tired landlords in hall
who or negative equity leads in
wholesale
from the prices in 2008 2007
i've seen that buyer prices for
ridiculous and the values
yeah exactly and then and then alongside
that
maybe do a biorefurbish refinance deal
on a joint venture
but the thing is in three four months
let's say you've got three lease option
agreements
at least option to hmo and you've got
your little house
going through you're gonna feel so
confident and experienced by that point
you're gonna have so much
cred you're going to be able to start
saying to other football players
but hey do you want to do a jv i found
this little fix and flip
and it needs 50 grand caps if you put
the money in i'll manage it and we'll go
50 50 on the profits boom exactly
especially in the football um the
society
everyone serves football but in terms of
property there's so much out there
especially for the money that
some companies are making nowadays you
could do so much in it
that's a lot much yeah i mean there's
people there's there's people that have
got more money than cents they don't
know what to do with it
i've gotta sat in the bank making zero
point something percent
and if they see you doing well if they
know you and they see you doing well
that's what that's what some of these
other guys are getting like kev's having
that kev's having people now saying hey
can we do stuff
you know like crazy you approach kev now
all and guaranteed he'll be like
i've got a deal you want to put the
money in do you have a plan
do you have loads of contacts is it an
area that's kind of
uh got a good kind of property market at
the minute
yeah i mean yeah i mean i've got like
i've got students that are doing
very good things in hall like stuart
brown he's another guy he's done seven
by refurbished refinance hmos in hull
um so yeah i mean listen i can't say
that hall's like my
my patch but of course but i've got i've
got connections all over
all over the country so you know and on
the academy
we we we we connect you like crazy to
people because a lot of a lot of this
business it's the same as most things a
lot of
businesses in general it's it's not so
much what you know it's also who you
know yeah just connect
i think it's both it's what you know and
who you know so yeah
yeah so that's basically that so what so
so where did you want to go from here
how can we help you best
um no that was it really that was that
was all um i just wanted to know kind of
what strategy to to go 100
towards uh obviously i i mean i was
i've been doing a lot of research on the
biorefurbish refinance
stuff um and obviously that's what long
term i i do enjoy that but yeah
just a bit of clarity
no i understand that so basically if i
were you then from now i've been doing a
few things number one is i'll be looking
for a little house that you can buy
yourself
and finding a good mortgage broker i'm
happy to connect you to our broker
um if that helps but i really really
would prioritize number one
buying a house i think that's that's
mega
because we've been able to get such
cheap lending
and the fact that you know in july
you're able to get three tenants and
you're in halt i just think that's a
no-brainer so i think you
really really really really need to join
um
you know need to do that but i also
think as well joining the academy is
also for me
because without that you're probably
going to struggle with the lease option
agreements and
the network and all the market research
to really kill it like
a lot of people talk about it a lot of
people talk about doing this and doing
that but
what happens is they just they go and
have a bash and then they get a bit
stuck
um it'd be a bit like it would be like
you're a footballer imagine if you go
and say oh i'm going to play football
but i don't want to train
yeah yeah you always can happen you're
going to look stupid on the pitch
of course and it tells us you know it's
the same story i mean as i say i mean
sometimes i get people get upset with me
because they think i'm like
pressuring them to buy my training but
the facts of the matter are
any profession i mean property is the
most lucrative profession on the planet
you wanna
you wanna you wanna do it properly and
well and make a lot of money doing it
and you need to get trained like every
other profession of course
educate yeah yeah so if i were you i
would think okay
i want to do i want to buy a house i
want to get trained and do it properly
i'm not there's no mad rush i've got
till july when i need to get the house
already but i really really really you
know
with my only intention to see you win of
course
i would definitely make it happen
somehow and we can definitely stay in
touch
you know over the next few weeks and and
can't touch base with you but i'm glad
that you've invested something obviously
already which is awesome um
but yeah but i think your plan's good i
want to support you in it
i look forward to uh to see you win and
i think as well with that the thing is
without the academy what will happen is
you'll probably still buy the house
and you'll you know with the information
that you've got and the few contacts
that you've got and the bit of support
and obviously you're a smart guy you're
not stupid you know how to
talk to agents and just do basic stuff
what probably happened without the
academy is you'll buy a house it'll be
good you'll be fine
you'll put some tenants in it'll be fun
it'll be great it'd be really good
investment but then you've got no money
left to do anything else
and then you just kind of being you'll
be you'll become a bit stuck
as in terms of what to do next maybe
you'll have a little go you'll make some
calls you'll try and do some reception
agreements but it will just
it won't really work in the same way
that it would whereas if you do the
academy and buy the house together
2021 is just going to be a year yeah
exactly and especially
financially it can change one season and
it can all change
yeah it's true but listen if there's
anything else you need from us
um in terms of you know any advice or
or or if you want help with getting on
on board on the academy
when the time is ready uh you know just
drop a message in and
and we'll you know we'll assist you with
that and um
but yeah i i think it's a good plan if
you need if you need
us to connect you to anybody like a
broker or anything like that just ping
us a message over and we can make that
happen
and uh i'm excited to see you on the
academy real soon
yeah definitely i'm excited to meet you
as well for sure
awesome anything else okay that's so
good thank you
you're welcome ellie i'll speak to you
real soon okay take care thank you